I just published my Year Ahead 2023 letter,...
...looking at what's going to happen in the next 12 months and beyond.
Life is changing.
I'm about to become a grandfather.
I reflect on the challenges we have right now with climate change getting worse,...
...the Ukraine war, tough economic cycle,...
...but it's hopefully uplifting because I also share great innovations.
A great example is gene therapy could cure HIV; an AI-powered ultrasound machine...
...that will help save lives of moms and newborns;...
...climate technologies that will make it so the emissions from buildings...
...go down quite dramatically.
I'm excited that we can get back, making progress on tough issues.
I hope you'll take a few minutes to read...
...why I think we can make the future a lot better than the past.
You can check it out at gatesnotes.com.